- Hi, everyone.
I'm Maurie Samuels, the
Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Anti-Semitism,
and on behalf of YPSA, the
Whitney Humanities Center,
and the department of Germanic
languages and literatures
at Yale, it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here today
to our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series.
Today's speaker Alex Ross,
a fellow Harvard '90 alum,
has written about music
for the New York Times,
the New Republic, the
London Review of Books,
among many other publications.
And he's been the music critic
of the New Yorker Magazine
since the 1990s.
Alex has won a slew of major prizes,
including the MacArthur Genius Grant.
His first book,
"The Rest is Noise: Listening
to the 20th Century"
was published in 2007
and won the National Book
Critics Circle Award,
was a finalist for the Pulitzer,
and was named one of the
10 best books of the year
by the New York Times.
His second book, "Listen to This,"
a collection of his essays,
was published in 2010, and
his new book right here,
"Wagnerism, Art and Politics
in the Shadow of Music"
from which his talk today is
drawn was published last year.
This book took more than a decade of work,
but it's really amazing that
it didn't take even longer.
Alex has seemingly tracked
down every reference
to Wagner in literature,
art, dance, philosophy,
you name it, over the past 150 years
and in every major European language.
As he puts it on page 15, "The
book has socialist Wagner,
"feminist Wagner, gay Wagner,
Black Wagner," et cetera.
It's all there and analyzed
with a keen sensitivity to
the way that artistic forms
produce political and social meaning.
The book is encyclopedic
but also incredibly engaging
and entertaining to read.
It gives a grand overview of
modern and modernist culture
through the lens of Wagner.
So let me just say a word
about how things are gonna work today.
Alex is gonna talk for
about 30 or 35 minutes,
and then I'll lead a discussion with him.
Please submit questions
to me using the Q&A button
at the bottom of your screen.
And you can send questions at any time,
even during the talk.
Please though, don't use the chat feature
or don't raise your hand.
We can't see or hear you, and
we'll end promptly at six.
So now I will turn it over to Alex.
His title today is
"The Unforgiven Wagner:
Jews and Antisemitism."
- Thank you so much, Maurie,
for the very kind introduction,
and it is wonderful to be invited
to this distinguished series
to talk about a very charged
and difficult question
which is the composer
Richard Wagner's relationship
with Jewishness, with anti-Semitism,
with the ideology of hate
that underpinned the Nazi regime,
with the Holocaust itself.
Wagner is part of these stories
to a very disturbing extent,
but at the same time
he is a gigantic figure
in cultural history who has touched upon
and has touched so many different worlds,
so many different people
of variegated backgrounds
in a way that it becomes, I think,
risky to categorize Wagner
purely as being aligned
with one ideological strain or another,
one political strain or another.
And the mission that I undertook
with this book was to give as expansive
and perhaps as contradictory a picture
of this phenomenon of Wagnerism,
Wagner's influence outside
of music on the arts,
on literature, on intellectual
life, on philosophy,
and of course on politics as well
to give as rich and ambiguous a picture.
And really, I hope as faithful,
as representative a
picture of that influence
as I could to counter act to some degree,
the more limiting perspective
that so many people have
on Wagner today, which
is to equate him entirely
with Nazi Germany, entirely
with anti-Semitism.
That's really the one
thing that people now know
about Wagner is that he was
Hitler's favorite composer.
And while that is true
and while in no way do I
want to push that aspect
of the Wagner narrative to the side,
it becomes more and more
central as the book goes on.
I do want to give the rest of the picture
and to under show how
extraordinarily widespread
Wagner's influence was at
the turn of the last century,
including his effect on
Jews, on African-Americans,
on gay people, on feminists,
on far left-wing figures,
socialists, communists anarchists,
sort of all across the political spectrum,
all across the cultural spectrum,
and then to ask how was
it that Wagner's image
became more and more confined
by the darker side of his legacy.
And I want to make very
clear, I do not think
this is a sort of unpleasant
accident that happened to him.
It is something that
he brought on himself,
and the superb formulation of that
I found in the writings of Thomas Mann,
which really I think gets
to the heart of the problem
that we're facing with Wagner
is that Wagner, Thomas Mann once said,
Wagner was a passionate and
devoted follower or admirer
of Wagner who was also at the
same time, deeply skeptical
of Wagner, had this enormous
ambivalence towards Wagner
in a way that I personally
find to be a model
as someone who also listens
with great admiration
to Wagner's music and also
with a great deal of doubt.
Anyway, what Mann said was
that Wagner lent himself
to his own misuse.
And so I think that's quite
an elegant formulation
that on the one hand captures the extent
to which Wagner was
manipulated, exploited distorted
in Nazi Germany especially,
but at the same time
he was involved in that process.
And his anti-Semitism was
absolutely, of course,
at the core of the role that
he played in subsequent events,
the means by which he became such a dark
and menacing figure in
so many people's lives.
Now there's a slew of
very complicated issues
to be confronted here which I
have little hope of covering
in any detail in half an hour,
but I thought I could
give a very quick overview
of some of the issues, sort
of lay out the territory
and then really invite a
conversation on any points
that arrest people's attention
or raise questions or objections.
And just to continue this conversation
which is so important.
And, you know, the thing that I would say
about Wagner and the questions
that hang over Wagner
is that this is a very,
very old conversation.
It's been going on for a very long time.
There's nothing new about it.
I was actually a little bit amused.
In recent years especially as questions
were increasingly being
asked about famous artists,
especially in the sort of popular world
and the me too movement and
quote unquote cancel culture
and everything else.
And some people were asking me,
are you worried about Wagner
as you've written this
big book about Wagner,
and, you know, now sort
of this kind of figure
is inviting more scrutiny.
And of course, you know,
it's certainly not the case
that Wagner just up until
recent years has been beloved
and revered and then suddenly
people are asking questions about him.
No, the trouble with
Wagner began in the 1850s,
already in the 1850s, people are asking
is Wagner too horrible for
us to listen to his music?
Does it have anything to do with him?
And yet, somehow he is still here.
And so there's something about his work
that compels attention
and will not going away.
I think precisely for that reason,
I think it's so valuable for us
to continue looking at Wagner
and even using this
endless debate over Wagner
as a model for how we deal
with other troubling figures
in our cultural history.
Because, you know,
especially in recent decades,
a very sophisticated
methodology has emerged
for analyzing Wagner's anti-Semitism,
for analyzing the impact on his works.
And then for dealing with sort
of how we look at the works,
how they are staged in the opera house
and ways in which we can isolate
and accentuate those questions
and not just sort of brush them aside.
And so there's something in
this endless Wagner controversy,
I think, that is edifying as we gaze
with a more skeptical eye at the heritage
of Western civilization,
which has sort of so many
troubling questions behind it
in so many ways.
So to go back almost to the beginning,
the trouble started at 1850
when Wagner published an essay
in the distinguished magazine
"Neue Zeitschrift für Musik"
founded by Robert Schumann,
titled "Das Judenthum in der Musik"
Jewishness in Music.
This was not out of the blue.
It was part of an ongoing debate
that had been taking place
in that publication and
other musical publications
about Jewish composers and
especially about Meyerbeer
who had achieved and
still held enormous fame
as an opera composer.
And there was a camp of
younger German composers
as well as music historians and critics
who were trying to combat this influence
of Meyerbeer and establish space
for the radical new,
so-called new German school
of Wagner and Liszt.
And so Wagner contributed to this debate.
Little of the vocabulary
of this essay was new.
This idea, central to the
essay, that Jewish people
are somehow alien to
German musical culture,
to sort of musical cultural,
European musical culture in general,
that it's, somehow they
betray their otherness
as they attempt to master musical speech.
This was not a new argument.
There was something new
about the sheer force,
the violence of Wagner's language,
and Wagner was a violent writer.
He was insistent.
He endlessly repeated his slogans and his,
stichworte is the German
word, his buzzwords.
He was very good at coining
these buzzwords and slogans.
And he would just sort of pound away.
And so there's an insistence
of violence in this essay,
Which contributed in some way, I think,
to the radicalization of
anti-Semitism in German discourse
in the middle of the 19th century.
The essay wasn't noticed.
It was talked about, and
actually within a few years,
I should have mentioned that
it was published anonymously
under a pseudonym, but Wagner's
authorship became known
and was actually discussed in England
by critics who were very
friendly to Mendelssohn's music
in particular and who took great offense
at Wagner's critique of
Mendelssohn alongside Meyerbeer
as a Jewish composer, who
was someone not truly German
or not sort of truly authentic.
And so this is really the
beginning of the critique
of Wagner's anti-Semitism
as something quite dangerous
in cultural discourse.
But within a few years,
discussion ebbed away,
and it really wasn't very
widely discussed to begin with,
this essay, and if Wagner
had left it at that,
I think we would be looking
at all of these issues
in a different way, but
he returned to the topic
of Jewishness and particularly
important was his decision
in 1869 to re-publish this
essay now under his own name,
very widely distributed
in a way that called
enormous attention to it.
And in the process, he added an afterward,
which extended the attack on
Jews in quite nasty new ways.
And his focus was now not
so much Jewish composers,
but Jewish music critics,
especially the critic Hanslick
who had emerged as his leading skeptic.
And from then on, Wagner
was known as an anti-Semite
and has been known as such ever since.
Yes, it was very controversial.
There was a great deal of
distress over the essay,
including from among Wagner's allies.
Just many people found it
quite dismaying and repulsive.
There was also amusement over this essay.
People found it ridiculous in many ways
to attack Mendelssohn who
really assumed such a major role
in sort of posthumously
this very grand status
in the the musical canon.
There were also sort of rumors swirling
that Wagner himself might be Jewish,
and that this was all some
kind of psychological implosion
sort of taking place within him
that he was becoming hysterical
on the subject of Jews,
and I'll show on the screen-share here
a somewhat disturbing cartoon.
Such, and the title here is
"Darwiniftifche Entwidlungslebre,"
"Darwinian Evolutionary Theory."
And you can see pretty
easily what's happening here.
An anti-Semitic stereotype is evolving
into the figure of Wagner.
It is sort of an anti-Semitic image
that also attacks Wagner's anti-Semitism.
Rather a troubling, complex
phenomenon in itself.
And so there was this derision of Wagner
that was seen, especially
in Vienna at the time.
Antisemitism in 1869 had not achieved
the kind of lethal political strength
that it would achieve.
And in a fairly short period of time,
especially going into the 1880s.
So there was a sense that
Wagner's version of anti-Semitism
was not quite aligned with
the political discourse
at the end of the 1860s,
but things changed.
After the crash of 1873, anti-Semitism
really gathered strength
as a way of shifting blame onto Jews.
Various other forces contributed
to this gathering intensity
of anti-Semitism,
and the shift from a more religiously
or economically based
form of anti-Jewishness.
And I'm sure you've
discussed this kind of shift
often in the series
toward this pseudo-scientific,
biologically defined notion
of Jewish otherness as a genetic otherness
which of course would become
the foundation of elimination,
this anti-Semitism in the 20th century,
this idea that there was
something ineradicably different
about Jewish people that
no degree of assimilation
or conversion would address.
Now a very big question in the discussion
of Wagner's anti-Semitism is
did he himself complete this transition
from the older form of
anti-Semitism to the newer one?
And of course it has to be stressed
that the older form of anti-Semitism
was by no means innocuous,
and thousands, millions of
people suffered and died
under the force of that
version of anti-Semitism.
But it is nonetheless an
important question, you know.
Did Wagner himself undergo,
completed that evolution?
And my feeling is that he didn't quite.
You can sort of have a sense reading
"Das Judenthum in der Musik"
that he seems to be seeing
Jews as innately other,
and no matter how hard they try,
they cannot master the language
of German art, German music,
and there's sort of something in them
which cannot be overcome, and
that is a sort of troubling,
early indicator of that kind
of biological mentality,
but then still in his later writings
which are full of ghastly
language borrowed from Gobineau
and other racial thinkers,
still there's this sense,
the suggestion that he throws out
that somehow there could
be this transfiguration,
this sort of transformation
that he says would raise
even the lowest races upwards
under the blessed umbrella
of the sort of spiritual emanation
of a pure Christian idea,
the kind of emanation
that one might find at
Bayreuth in the Festspielhaus
at Bayreuth, and
performances of "Parsifal."
And, you know, this is not
a very generous concession
on Wagner's part by any means.
But I think there is a sense that there's,
that he doesn't quite go all the way
in terms of this sort of movement
toward the biological anti-Semitism.
And of course, there's the fact
that he had many Jews
around him in Bayreuth.
And this gets into another issue
of Wagner's own personal
relationships with Jews
which are very complicated
and sort of ultimately
hard to make sense of
in many ways.
The, his Jewish friends and
especially subordinates,
sort of helpers, underwent
a fair amount of humiliation
in his presence.
But at the same time, there
was a genuine friendship
or sort of fondness on Wagner's part,
and no one was compelling
him to, you know,
undertake these relationships.
There's something very
complicated going on
sort of some of this sort of need
to kind of have Jews around him,
but also to control them
or to sort of put them
in subordinate positions.
Strange, dark psychological
questions with Wagner.
Jews were an obsession,
a lifelong obsession
that he could never let go of
and that sort of at times
seemed to sort of dominate
his consciousness.
And he believed that ultimately
Jews were going to be victorious.
And that sort of perhaps he felt
that when he himself had to submit
in some ways to Jewish presence
and to sort of control it
as much as he could on
his own sort of territory.
It's difficult to speculate,
dangerous to speculate
exactly what was going on,
but it was there's something
different about it.
There's something singular about it
as against so much of the
anti-Semitism that you find
in Germany and Austria and
other European countries
in this period.
Another great question which arises,
a question for which I honestly
do not have a fixed answer
is can one detect anti-Semitism
in the works themselves?
And there's been a great deal of writing,
a great deal of powerful
and intelligent scholarship
on the question of characters
like Alberich and Mime,
the dwarves, the conniving
dwarves and the ring,
Beckmesser, the conniving Meistersinger,
Merker, a musical judge,
really sort of a metaphor
for a music critic
in "Die Meistersinger,"
perhaps Klingsor, the evil
sorcerer in "Parsifal,"
certainly the figure of Kundry,
the mysterious eternal
wanderer in "Parsifal."
Are these Jewish figures?
Very early on, there was open
speculation on this point.
And actually there were protests
at early performances of Meistersinger
because Jewish opera-goers felt that,
feared that Beckmesser was
going to turn out to be
a Jewish stereotype.
Somehow that that idea did not take hold
even though it was sort
of in the public arena,
and so after those early performances,
it's very difficult to
find commentary, excuse me,
commentary on Meistersinger
which brings up
this Jewish Beckmesser issue.
So either in the sort of Jewish world
or in the kind of antisemitic
press and commentary,
even right into the Nazi period,
you simply don't find it.
The scholar David Dennis made
a very, very thorough search
for such discussions of Beckmesser
and could not find them.
In the case of Alberich and Mima,
you do see mentions of the idea
including from none
other than Gustav Mahler
that these are Jewish
caricatures of sorts,
but they were not terribly widespread.
This was not kind of one
of the dominant lenses
through which people
viewed the work of Wagner.
It's really only in the
post-World War II era,
the post-Holocaust era that
the question of Jewishness
in the Wagner operas has come to the fore.
The great philosopher Ted
Adorno was one of the first
to advance this idea when he said
all of the outcasts in
Wagner's work are Jews.
And then as I mentioned,
a number of significant scholars
have taken up this issue
in recent decades.
The question remains unsettled.
It's a very powerful and plausible idea,
but because there's no evidence
that Wagner intended it,
and Wagner was not the kind of person
who kept his intentions to himself.
We sort of have to assume
that this was either a secretive
or even a kind of unconscious
intention on his part,
which may be so.
I think there is something there,
but I find it very difficult to pin down
and to be sort of
absolutely certain about.
And I'm hesitant when
people sort of take it as
sort of absolutely obvious and proven
that the Wagner operas are anti-Semitic
that they contain
anti-Semitic caricatures.
I think that's going too far.
And in terms of Wagner's
relationship with Nazism,
I don't think this is
something that I can go into
in any detail because this
is such a huge question
in and of itself, but I
think it's worth noting
that in terms of the particular rhetoric
of Wagner's anti-Semitism,
it was not one of the primary sources
on which the Nazis drew
for their kind of anti-Semitic
sort of anthologies
of kind of sort of anti-Semitic writings.
Jewishness of music would be there.
Goebbels would quote one of
the late essays on occasion.
Wagner saying that the
Jews are the plastic demon
of the downfall of mankind,
whatever that means exactly.
Hitler never quoted Wagner
on the subject of Jews.
He never made any mention
of Wagner's anti-Semitism.
If he undoubtedly knew that
Wagner was anti-Semitic,
he undoubtedly had read the essay,
but he didn't find it
useful to quote Wagner
on these points.
And I think the reason for
that is sort of surprising,
sort of sense that in Nazi Germany,
Wagner is not a sort of Titan
of anti-Semitic thought.
His writing is strange,
confusing, contradictory,
bewildering, and sort of lacking
in the kind of cretinous
clarity that did you find
in sort of anti-Semitic
writing of a later period.
And it was more useful, Wagner
was more useful to the Nazis
as this grand cultural figurehead
who seemed in some way or another
to anticipate Nazi Germany
to sort of herald
the sort of hyper
nationalist Nazi German State
sort of rather than a sort
of more precise precursor,
particularly with respect
to anti-Semitic ideology.
There were some Nazis who disliked Wagner
who found him sort of an
inauthentic anti-Semite.
They found him decadent,
questionable on various grounds.
In previous periods there
were a number of anti-Semites,
(Audio Blurs) and Paul de Lagarde
who cannot abide Wagner and
found him to be repulsive
and sort of useless to their movement.
And so by saying all this, I'm
not trying to separate Wagner
from the history of anti-Semitism.
He is there.
He plays an important role,
but I think it's a slightly
more marginal position
than a kind of typical short
presentation of the matter
would have you think
that sort of Wagner was
Hitler's favorite composer.
Wagner sort of dictated
anti-Semitism to Hitler
that he was an absolutely
formative presence.
I think to sort of assign too
much responsibility to Wagner
is to let everyone else
off the hook in a way.
And, you know, the roots of anti-Semitism
go very, very deep, back centuries
not just in German culture and history
but European culture and history,
Christian history, and around the world.
And so Wagner plays a role,
but not quite as large a role
as I think some would have you think.
The last matter that I wanna touch on
before taking up any of your questions is,
in a way the most interesting one
and the one that I spend
the most time on in the book
which is Jewish Wagnerites.
There were a great many of them,
not just those who were
directly around Wagner
in Bayreuth, and many
other places that he lived
throughout his life, but in the audience,
among some of the most vociferous,
enthusiastic Wagner fans.
And in later generations,
through especially into
the Fantasque period,
a great many enthusiasts.
Not necessarily worshipers,
but enthusiasts,
people who took Wagner seriously
and found him inspiring or
sort of thought-provoking
in one way or another.
One of them was Theodore Herzl
as I talk about in the book,
and a sort of remarkable moment
in the history of Jewish Wagnerism
is when Herzl is in Paris
in 1896, writing "Der Judenstaat,"
the founding document
of the Zionist state,
the prospectus of the Zionist
state, and at the same time
"Tannhäuser," Wagner's
"Tannhäuser" is playing
at the opera in Paris.
And Herzl goes to see it
every time it's staged
throughout its run.
And he says in his diary
that only on the nights
when the opera was not performed
did he lack inspiration,
lack conviction for what he was doing,
for what he was writing.
And so there's this sense of
which, by his own testimony,
the music of "Tannhäuser" is emboldening,
is empowering Herzl as he works.
And this is something
that we find very often
at the turn of the century,
sort of the late 19th century
into the early 20th century,
especially younger people who go to Wagner
and feel what W.E.B. Dubois,
another Wagnerian enthusiast called,
a movement of power, a
sense of movement of power
within the spectator,
and a sense of visions
of future possibility,
future greatness, sort of a feeling
that one's ambitions are
mirrored back to oneself
in more heightened form
as one listens to Wagner and sees Wagner.
And of course this mechanism
can take a much darker form.
Adolf Hitler was exactly
one of those young people
who felt vague feelings
of of future greatness
when he first started seeing
Wagner operas in Linz.
But nonetheless, it's just a
very wide spread phenomenon,
and you find it with Jewish Wagnerites,
and there isn't, it isn't necessarily
a case of sort of the the
tortured or self-hating Jew.
There's been a lot of discourse
about Jewish self-hatred
and a lot of critiques of the
idea of Jewish self-hatred
back and forth.
Obviously, Wagner is a kind
of very promising territory
in which to pursue that theme.
And you do find a number of
Jews who are very conservative,
who are seeking to sort of
assimilate themselves completely,
who are disgusted by their Jewishness
and want to somehow erase
it from their being,
and listening to Wagner,
becoming absorbed in Wagner
is part of that mechanism
of sort of transforming themselves.
And there's the very dark story
of the philosopher Otto
Weininger who killed himself
at a very young age after
writing what would become
the best selling tracked
sex and character,
racist and misogynist document
of startling strangeness.
As we revisit it now, he was also gay.
And then, so this,
the phenomenon of the self-hating
Jewish Wagnerite is real
and actually novelists and playwrights
made fun of such a figure.
You find it in Carl
Sternheim and Schnitzler
and some others, but then you have others
who were not in a sort of a
state of psychological agony
and torment as they listened to Wagner.
Hetzel certainly seems to be one of those.
And of course there are questions
with Hetzel about his relationship
with Eastern European Jewishness,
and his urge to sort of distance himself
from sort of certain
forms of Jewish culture.
Yes, but I don't think
anyone can realistically
describe Hetzel as a self-hating Jew.
And again, sort of Wagner was,
he didn't seem to view Wagner
purely as an anti-Semite,
even as he was very aware
of Wagner's anti-Semitism.
It was a separation that
he could make in his mind,
and you find that with a number
of other Jewish Wagnerites.
And so this is something
where I think we need to
look at the past especially
with a certain compassion
and a certain sophistication,
and not with a kind of extreme
self-righteous judgmentalism.
In the introduction of the book,
I mention the late critic
Michael Andre Bernstein
and his idea of back shadowing,
this idea that we evaluate the literature
of the pre-Holocaust era, and
he was talking specifically
about Jewish literature
in this case, you know,
through the lens of what came after,
and judging sort of figures
of this period by, you know,
whether or not they were
sensitive to rising anti-Semitism
or whether they were oblivious to it.
And so I think in the same way
when we look at, excuse
me, Jewish Wagnerism,
we need to see its many varieties.
And we need to realize that
no one or almost no one
had any idea of what was coming,
and anti-Semitism was simply not
one of the really defining characteristics
that the people would
name attached to Wagner
in that period.
It was something that a lot
of people were embarrassed by,
just would sort of
prefer not to talk about.
It was very important, and
it was very important in,
there were radical anti-Semitic circles,
but with this book, I'm
essentially presenting a vast
and unresolved question of, you know,
what do we do with this
titanic and troubling figure
and his legacy and the sort of the
all the contradictory
aspects of his legacy,
and Wagner and Jews and anti-Semitism
is really the most obvious case study
of Wagner's questionableness,
sort of problematic nature.
But there are many, it takes
many, many other forms.
And I think there is a reason
why Wagner is still with us.
And what I end up saying at
the end of the book is that
a kind of demystification
takes place with Wagner.
No one can really, no one
who's sensible and rational
can any longer put Wagner
on some kind of pedestal
and sort of worship him
and sort of treat him as
a sort of a pure emanation
of a higher sphere.
We cannot forget the history.
We cannot forget the context,
but I think that's very healthy
to always sort of treat
art as a historical
and human phenomenon
and not to separate it,
not to sort of elevate it and abstract it.
And I think in our own
culture, in American culture,
we have problems with our veneration
of certain cultural figures,
veneration of our own popular culture
which we tend to think
of as pure and innocent
and sort of coming up
from the sort of people,
and sort of combating
the elite and aristocracy
and sort of power and so on and so forth.
But in fact, there are deep,
deep troubling questions
about our own cultural
legacy and the sort of idea
that I place at the end of the book
is especially that we as
Americans have a great deal
to learn from the case of Wagner,
the famous case of Wagner
as we look at ourselves
and as we look at our own
problematic cultural inheritance.
So on that point I will come to an end
and would be happy to field
any and all questions.
It's Wagner.
No one's gonna have any questions.
- Exactly, no, there are a
lot of questions already,
so I will try to synthesize them.
And that was fantastic.
So thank you so much for that.
I think you really gave
us a lot to think about
and a great way to kind of, you know,
think about the question,
the problem of Wagner.
So to start out, I think,
can you say a little bit more
about the context for the essay,
for the 1850 "Das Judenthum
in der Musik" essay?
So why exactly did he
have it in for Meyerbeer?
I mean, Meyerbeer was nice
to him in a lot of ways.
Like where was all this
hatred coming from?
- Yeah, well, I sort of
skipped over the question
of the origins of Wagner's
anti-Semitism before 1850,
and it was sort of creeping
to the forefront, I think,
in the 1840s.
You know, there was also, there
was a lot of anti-Semitism
on the left, and so Wagner
was a part of the left
in the 1840s and participated
in the revolutions of 1848
and had to leave Germany in 1849
and spent more than a decade in exile.
And as he was aligned with
sort of democratic ideas
and sort of revolutionary ideas,
at the same time he was
picking up anti-Semitism
from figures on the left.
And of course we have the
issue of Karl Marx's own essay
on the Jewish question,
and the far less radical
kind of anti-Jewish language
that you find there.
So it was circulating.
And it was like that may have been
sort of some of the
context in which Wagner
was first picking up this discourse,
but then it was fused
with his personal
obsessions and resentments,
and so this is where Meyerbeer
comes into the picture.
He left Germany in 1849.
Shortly after he saw Meyerbeer,
Meyerbeer's "Le Prophète" in Paris,
and it was a huge success,
and he was enraged.
And I think the sort of contrast
between Meyerbeer's ongoing
success as a German composer
who had settled in Paris
and his own failure
and sort of outcast, outsider status
set off some kind of rage in him, I think.
So I failed to say that
this sort of anti-Semitism
was already becoming
part of his discourse,
but sort of it was that
point, that kind of jealousy
it sort of, at which
it became radicalized,
but it wasn't just about Meyerbeer.
He just fell into a psychological
habit of blaming Jews,
scapegoating Jews for his own setbacks
which were so often created
by his own profligacy
and combativeness and sort
of general sort of messiness
in terms of how he dealt with the world.
He would find a way to blame
Jews for those setbacks.
And this became a recurring
kind of psychological obsession.
So it was kind of a mix
of these sort of environmental forces
kind of working around him and
his own sort of compulsion,
personal compulsion coming to the fore.
And it's that compulsion,
which sort of gives,
which gives that essay and
sort of all his subsequent
sort of writings on Jews,
it's what makes them so disturbing
because it's not a theory.
It's not an ideological ideology.
It's a passion.
This is something that comes
from very deep within him,
and he confessed that in a
letter to Liszt, you know.
It's vital to him.
He needs, he needs this hatred.
It fuels him, and you find
this in other artistic figures
with when anti-Semitism comes to the fore.
You find it in T.S. Eliot.
It's very disturbing to see anti-Semitism
becoming part of the creative process.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
you also sort of, you know,
it seems to me like, you know,
there's this phenomenon here
of a kind of relation to capitalism.
The Jews are kind of representing
this sort of relation to capitalism
that's inspiring a lot of intense
emotions, not just in him,
but you know, in other people too,
including a certain
kind of ambivalence too.
So they're kind of desiring
this sort of new
relationship to the market
at the same time that
they're sort of hating that
in themselves.
So a few questions about the essay itself.
So someone asked whether isn't it true
that he gives some praise for,
I'll maybe ask these
three questions together,
and you can, you know,
answer them if you want.
So isn't it true that he gives some praise
for Jewish virtuosic instrumentalists
at the same time as he, you know,
heaps invective on
composers like Meyerbeer?
And although he doesn't
name them, I don't think.
My memory is he doesn't
name Meyerbeer, but--
- He doesn't, yeah, which is
sort of all the more cowardly
that he wrote this anonymous essay,
attacking Meyerbeer
without naming Meyerbeer.
But everyone knew exactly
who he was talking about.
- And then, so isn't it true
that he has some admiration
for Jewish performers?
- Mildly, I mean, virtuosity
is a charged word.
You know, it sort of can
become sort of mere virtuosity,
kind of mere mechanical brilliance
which is soulless, you know,
and he said the same
thing about Italian opera.
There was this sort of brilliant
display that's meaningless,
and, you know, covers up
kind of the, you know,
cultural vacancy and is not
kind of the true, hearty voice
of the folk.
It's sort of this sort
of aristocratic frippery.
And so, yeah, he has sort
of mild, mild praise,
but I wouldn't put sort of
too much emphasis on that.
You know, he also, he
also praises to a degree
Birna and Heine, really
for being so scathing
toward themselves, sort of becoming models
of Jewish self-hatred sort of almost.
And so that's another, you know, and he,
he did, I mean, he could
never bring himself
to fully praise Heine, but
he took an enormous amount
from Heine and sort of elements,
so many elements of the early
operas, "Flying Dutchman"
and "Tannhäuser" in
particular come from Heine.
And I think there was, I think the essay
is trying to sound like Heine in some way.
It is sort of attempting
to sort of model itself
on this brilliant polemic
that Heine and Birna both practiced.
And that he just falls short
because it's just not funny.
I mean, it's not just not funny
because of everything that came after,
it's just not good comic
writing by any standard.
And it's just, it's villainous,
and it's kind of plodding and ponderous,
and so it's, but I think that
there was some emulation,
hidden emulation there.
- So, you know, in the essay, he says,
not only the Jews are
alien to German culture,
but he also implies that they're incapable
of producing real art, right?
That they can only ever
imitate or kind of parody,
and, you know, so there's
a question about whether,
you know, that's definitely
a trope that you see
in later anti-Semites.
So like, you know, I'm thinking
of someone like Drehmel,
you know, at the end of the
19th century and certainly,
you know, into the 20th.
So, but is that, do you know
whether that's new with Wagner?
Is he?
- That's not new, I mean, Franz Brendel.
the editor of the "Neue
Zeitschrift für Musik"
had said the same thing
in an earlier essay.
I think also Theodor Uhlig, another,
especially Theodor Uhlig
rather than Brendel
had said, really made the same
claim about Jewish musicians,
Jewish composers in an earlier essay
that had set off this debate.
And there were, there was another critic
Ludvig Bishop who was defending
Mendelssohn and Meyerbeer
and saying this
anti-Jewishness is ridiculous.
And sort of hitting back in that degree,
and so that's where Wagner stepped in,
but no, this point had already been made
specifically about Jewish composers,
but Wagner fleshed it out certainly.
He went on at greater length,
and he, that vehemence,
that repetitiveness kind
of solidified this idea.
It was no longer something
that had been thrown out in passing
in the middle of this
back and forth debate,
in-fighting among kind
of German music critics
and commentators.
It became, it's, the
essay was just long enough
that it just became a
statement on its own.
And people forgot about
the context of the various
sort of polemics back and forth,
especially when it was being published.
Then all of that,
all of that prior
discussion had disappeared.
And so, although I wouldn't say that it's,
that it was anything
particularly original about the,
just purely the content of the
claims that Wagner is making,
in terms of this, the sweeping
cultural attack on Jews
as infiltrators, as
imposters in German culture,
the scale on which he
carried it out, that was new.
- Yeah, and he, you know, quickly,
there was a question about
like how far he went.
You know, did he call for extermination?
I know Cosima is not, you know,
she even goes, you know,
she goes pretty far too.
But how far does his anti-Semitism go?
- I think there have been claims
that especially the ending of this essay
where he calls for "der untergang,"
the untergang is a
complicated German word.
"Going under" is the literal translation,
but it also means kind
of downfall, destruction.
It can also be sort of
a philosophical idea
of sort of this kind of downfall
that turns into this transformation.
Hegel and sort of others sort
of use the concept this way.
It's sort of hard to read, you know,
and so it can be read in
several different ways.
I think in the context,
it seems as though Wagner
is in fact talking about
not quite sort of assimilation,
but this idea that he returns to,
is sort of at the at the
end in his later essay,
some kind of,
some kind of apocalyptic
spiritual transformation
which would somehow
just solve this problem.
And it can seem menacing.
I think to equate it with the Holocaust
or to equate it with a
sort of genocidal program
is just, makes no sense
whatsoever in this context.
And no one treated it as such.
You don't find Nazi theorists
that are citing the ending of this essay,
but it's chilling, you know,
just because of the way it ends
with this word
which sort of clangs out on the page.
It's, the vehemence of it is disturbing.
Later, you know, it emerged,
and when Cosima's diaries were published,
that he had made,
he had joked about the
terrible theater fire in Vienna
where hundreds of people
died including many Jews,
and he'd sort of joked
about it and said something
to the effect of all Jews should be burned
at a performance of "Nathan the Wise."
You know, an utterly
horrible thing to say,
but again to sort of go from there
to sort of he is plotting
the Holocaust, I think,
is to go too far.
And, so there were, he
had violence, I think,
violent fantasies and
sort of violent thoughts,
but it's just, in no way,
I think, can you really
collect these sort of scattered
utterances into a program.
Of course this was a remark
that emerged in the 1970s
and sort of had nothing to do
with the sort of earlier history.
- So I was really fascinated
by your discussion
of Afro Wagnerism, you know.
And the fascination of
prominent Black intellectuals
for Wagner especially W.E.B.
Dubois, who you, you know,
describe going to Bayreuth in 1936.
And, you know, so can you say
a little bit more about that
and about, and did Dubois,
like was he aware of the
Wagner's anti-Semitism?
Did he comment on it?
Like how did, how did?
- Yeah, it's a fascinating case.
And this sort of emerged as
I was working on this chapter
of the book where I talked
about Wagner race and racism,
the sixth chapter of the book,
it was originally really
gonna be all about
the Jewish question.
And I thought I'd mentioned
Black Wagnerites as well
because I was aware of Dubois
and his love of Wagner.
But then it sort of took
on greater weight for me,
as I explored more of Dubois
and his commentary on Wagner,
and as I found other figures,
other Black figures,
intellectuals and artists.
Who had a relationship with Wagner,
Alain Locke,
Shirley Graham who later married Dubois,
Langston Hughes was very fond of Tristan.
Ralph Ellison in his
youth listened to Wagner.
And so it was something
of a motif, you know,
among the Black intellectuals
of this certain generation.
And so I was curious about, so
what do they find in Wagner?
And then I discovered
this extraordinary figure
of Luranah Aldridge, the Contralto
who was contracted to
sing at Bayreuth in 1896.
she was the daughter of the
great Black Shakespearian actor
Ira Aldridge.
And despite the fact that
Cosima was, if anything,
more racist than her husband,
she was gonna sing one of the Valkyries
in the Ring at Bayreuth in
1896 until she fell sick.
And I was able to reconstruct
her story in a way
that hadn't been done before.
And so I began to feel that
this was actually a bigger theme
and should have a bigger
presence in this chapter,
but of course Dubois
is at the heart of it.
And really what's going on with Dubois
is this sort of mechanism
that I discussed earlier
of a figure from another
background, not a white German,
nonetheless finding inspiration
in Wagner's mythic apparatus
and seeing how this brilliant
modernization of myth
that takes place in Wagner's operas,
especially The Ring could be emulated.
And so it's about emulation.
And so what he talks about with Wagner
is he sees a sort of
future great Black art
that sort of uses the mythic past
especially sort of, you know,
African myths and legends
as Wagner used Nordic
and Germanic legends.
I wonder whether Dubois
might've been impressed
by the film "Black Panther" in this regard
because sort of this is
something of what's happening
in that case, but in
any event, it was that,
it was, I think there's also
kind of slightly kind of
insolent or defiant elements to Dubois,
sort of stepping in and
saying this is mine.
You know, this, these masterpieces
of white Western civilization
also belong to me.
I can take them.
I can make use of them,
convert them to my own ends.
So I think that's something also
what's going on with Herzl, you know.
And so there's a certain
defiance and pride
in how he takes hold of Wagner.
And then this extraordinary
story that appears
in "The Souls of Black Folk,"
"Of the Coming of John,"
very, you know, Dubois shouldn't
write that much fiction.
This is an extraordinary story,
and the crucial scene in it
is this young Black man has gone to school
and envisions his sort of
future kind of progress
in the world and becoming educated
and becoming sort of, it's a commentary
on Booker T. Washington
style kind of, you know,
Black improvement and
then sort of betterment.
And then there's this catastrophe
where he's at a concert
and the usher taps him on the shoulder
and says he has to leave.
The white woman sitting next
to him has become uncomfortable
by his presence, and then it turns out
this woman is with this white
childhood friend of his.
The whole story sort of
spirals toward disaster.
But the, as he's listening to the music,
and it's Wagner's "Lohengrin,"
the prelude to "Lohengrin"
He has this vision of some other worlds
that could be achieved that
he could sort of step into,
and it's denied to him.
And at the end of the story,
he's about to be lynched,
but the music is still
running through his head.
And I don't think Dubois,
and there's an ironic aspect to this,
but there's also, I think a sense,
and when Wagner, when
Dubois talks about Wagner,
he talks about he's transported by Wagner,
and it's sort of, there's
a vision here of something
in which one can believe and one can trust
that we can sort of carry with us
and that can sort of
inform our own struggles
toward a better future.
And so it's this, it's not sardonic
or sort of purely ironic
sort of circumstance
that he's setting up.
It's just a tragic, it's a
tragic one rather than ironic,
but it's quite powerful.
And it's just another,
just very surprising unexpected way
in which Wagner plays a role
in the culture of this period,
the Fantasque.
- Wow, all right, well, we're out of time.
We have, you know, 20 more
questions from the audience,
and I had 20 more.
So I feel like we could
have gone on for hours,
but I think we have to leave
it there unfortunately.
And thank you so much for this.
It was really, I just thought,
you know, fascinating,
and I recommend to
everyone to get the book.
I also want to do a pitch
for our last program
which is gonna be in two weeks.
It was gonna be in one week,
but it's actually gonna be
in two weeks, which is a
discussion with Jake McAuley
about his new book, "The
House of Fragile Things."
So mark your calendars for that.
And again, thank you so much, Alex.
I really appreciate your coming.
- A pleasure, thank you so much.
- And thank you to
everyone in the audience.
Bye.